[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's bonut of the week
this edition it has a theme this week it
is um the lackey trump attorneys is the
theme of the bonehead
poll this week
gabe he's got a lot of um really stupid
attorneys these television these
television attorneys is what they really
seem like now let's look at the
candidates here we have christina bob as
we know it's not just not just his
television attorney she's also
an old host on oan propaganda on oan but
more importantly she was in the
department of homeland security and
and she helped john eastman write the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup plan she's one
of the architects and was in the war
room with that trader steve bannon uh
rudy kaluti
rudy giuliani and also john eastman
himself uh jim trustee here
this guy has made an appearance here
all of a sudden um i don't even know who
this guy is but uh we're gonna find out
and then alina is it alina ahab a habba
is that yeah alina habba alina habba
there um our bonehead of the week uh
contestants here
and you guys voted and it was
overwhelmingly um which one was the
bonehead of the week and really honestly
i think the issue is
is that we really didn't get to see what
trustee you know we didn't get to see
his bone-headedness marinate enough yeah
i mean he was you know he's a he's a
he's a late comer right right he was a
late entertainer
a late what
a late comer okay i got you
what dude get your mind out of the
gutter i i'm just making sure what you
said yeah all right all right i'm trying
to do uh he he is uh he is late to enter
the race yeah okay gotcha into the legal
race which is trump's uh incompetent
uh
just
because watch these more [ __ ]
we watch these morons on on tv yeah
every time they go on every time they go
on they have the dumbest takes again
we're not lawyers i mean we you know
we'll we'll chat you know we'll chime in
with ben every now and again when these
new takes come out and he's like this is
so dumb right this is the most exciting
thing i've ever heard something that's
what we do is like before we go on a
show or make a video where it's like hey
we kind of need to know what the
what it actually is or isn't yeah we'll
either go on and we'll we'll figure out
if harry lipman or or popock or
or or glenn or someone's going to give
like some sort of explanation we'll go
we'll even go to uh allison with mueller
she wrote we're trying to find someone
who has some [ __ ] common sense and
sometimes we go to ben mizellis and
we're like hey
we need a quick answer on this we're
going to make a video some we're going
to say something we want to make sure
we're not
[ __ ] saying some dumb [ __ ] like these
stupid [ __ ] tv lawyers yeah so we'll
ask him a quick question and he'll
respond back like nope it's exactly what
you think they're [ __ ] dumb like yeah
why not so many words that's mine right
right and it's also like one of those
things like you know when we've we've
been in you know texting with him about
these
these motions that they've been
submitting right and even then he's like
this is
a hot mess man it doesn't make any sense
what's talking about arbitrary legal
theory what's funny when you watch vin
on like legal af or some of his like
breaking takes and he's he's
flabbergasted in those videos that is
actually that's authentic he is he is he
actually he's like like last night there
was that same type of like what are we
doing when we were doing the actual live
stream yesterday of biden speech like we
were talking about mar-a-lago and these
in these documents and these motions and
he was just like
ah this is as a lawyer it this hurts my
head right because this is not the way
it's supposed to go it's all backwards
and confused and the reason why is
because we're dealing with trump here
that's the reason why but all you new
listeners out there you have you have
entered the bonehead of the week segment
here on the tony michael's podcast what
happens we air every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch so go follow our youtube
channel at tony michael's podcast don't
forget to subscribe over there you can
watch every single show every single
weekday but bone end of the week
we put up a poll on twitter at
tonymichaelspot so follow us over there
you get to vote every single week
for bone end of the week of the
contestants that we put up and this week
we have all of trump's bone-headed
attorneys here yeah that's not even all
of them because there was a new there
was a new one that was released uh or
that was that was brought off the bench
right recently just on tuesday he's a
newcomer he's a newcomer canoe comer
he's or would i say a late comer late
comer yeah yeah late that's why i was
like late comer come on yeah
what is all this well you know what's
funny
i wanted to bring this up last night but
we were on the midas touch podcast yeah
and i feel like we can get away with
more [ __ ] over here on the tony michaels
podcast and bone into the week than they
can right there
because
they keep talking about a special master
right and then and then the special
master with the fbi they're a taint team
it just yeah it's i it man i don't know
what kind of gutter these attorneys
minds are in and these judges and people
who are making these names up but
special master taint team and now you're
saying late comer this is all this is
all getting very
it is very saucy very fast and i mean
they're at a certain point they're just
they're like look uh
these normal names aren't cutting it we
need something that everyone's gonna
remember right you know exactly exactly
so if you want to watch bone end of the
week watch it every single friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
or you can watch the replay right here
in prime time on the midas touch network
so don't forget to subscribe if you're
on the midas touch network channel to
subscribe now you can also
you trust download moment um because i
saw an ad you know that um out there for
trustee that seemed to be
you know he's kind of he's kind of cheap
he's not that expensive yeah
maybe that's the reason why he went with
trump went with him is because
well he's he saw him on uh he saw him on
tv and it was like that's the guy i need
right because that's literally how he
found him he saw him on fox news uh
because i haven't seen i haven't seen
him actually on any other network so i
would imagine it was fox news but only
fox news that is how
he hired jim trustee and this is this is
one of the pictures from fox news that
appears
because you you tweeted here meet jim
trusty one of the lawyers trump's hired
after seeing him on tv
and um
it appears here that you can hire jim
trustee for
184 easy payments
of
99.99 www trust me i'm jimtrusty.com
is this really his [ __ ] phone number
no no
that's not his actual i just put that
there but what i can say is that i am uh
i'm working i actually you know what
i'll play the video we'll play the video
do you want to play it put it in that
put it in yeah yeah yeah
okay but but this is this is a this will
be an updated uh
uh it's tr it's uh jimtrusty.com is the
updated uh url that we're gonna use
because i'm working with toby morgan oh
that's right after this happened he was
like oh i'm gonna buy the domain and so
then we've been chatting about it i um i
see but but uh the jim trustee thread
here um let's see put that video up and
we'll play it but um
uh here is here is actually an interview
here where he's talking about a special
master on fox news with i don't know who
this is but let's let's listen to the
trader stock pieces one in the wall
street journal over the weekend that
talks about the high bar and the huge
challenge another one of the new york
times that merrick garland has right now
he basically has two different cases
this raid at mar-a-lago and also the
january 6 issue
under which he could potentially
prosecute a former president of the
united states okay so right there like
you're laying it out yes there is a
high bar for criminality that is true
and yes merrick garland has two
opportunities so far
to prosecute at that eye bar for
criminality
and we're starting to see the evidence
because of trump and his legal team roll
out right in front of our eyes
of what they're gonna prosecute him for
and why they're going to like this is
not normal and that's what ben was
trying to say last night too like this
is not back in normal normally what a
defendant does is like oh [ __ ] i'm in
trouble
i need to batten down the hatches i need
to not say a thing and let my legal team
handle this [ __ ] yeah because if they
would have a decent legal team well
cause also it's the the things that he's
saying right if he's going on these
programs he's releasing these statements
on truth social he's you know going to
giving a speech somewhere
these are things that can and probably
will be used against him to say you had
intent clearly you're indicating that
you knew you had the documents right
these are all things that can go against
him and i'm very surprised that his
legal team isn't like yo
shut the hell up dude stop talking his
legal team can't shut the hell up oh
yeah no so let's listen to jim trustee
and see what
see what this guy has to say
so one of the things that's broken down
in here is the parallel that was created
by jim comey when he did a similar
investigation of information and
confidential documents that hillary
clinton kept on a private server okay if
it is the same
if there is a parallel here
what
could it have been that the moglodites
were saying about the hillary clinton
emails what could it possibly have been
i think there was a three letter or
three word chant that they were chanting
at rallies i can't remember exactly what
it was
i can't remember exactly what they were
calling for but you know there's
something there
and he came out at the time
and said that you know a they had held
back documents the clinton team they
held back documents after they said oh
we gave them all the classified
information um but yet they couldn't
prosecute so tell me what your take is
on on what is different or the same in
those two things and did that set a
precedent for handling this case that
cannot be
overturned okay so before [ __ ]
speaks here yeah
they're not the same it is not the same
it's not the same at all
she didn't steal any documents she
didn't take anything that didn't belong
to her the government wasn't asking her
to give something back that she took
that they needed
and when they did when they did request
the server she didn't have to have the
[ __ ] fbi come and get it they they
got the server went and they actually
gave it to them well she yeah they were
like look you can you can come on in you
can just take it you can get it right as
opposed to
we don't have it we don't know what
you're talking about and they're like
well we're pretty sure we know it's
missing and we tracked it down and we're
almost positive you have it somewhere
and probably have it here and he's like
no no we don't have it if we had it we
would have told you if we had it we
would have given it back to you and
they're like okay okay okay fine we have
it here is some of it and they're like
okay thanks and they take it back and
they're like oh well this isn't actually
all of it where's the rest of it like we
don't have it what are you guys talking
about like no we know you have it
they're like okay fine here's the rest
of it and again they're like
okay they're like [ __ ] it we're just
gonna come down and get it ourselves
right
clearly this whole like asking you for
it and you telling you gave it to us
isn't working out right well let's
listen to trusty here i'm sure we can
trust everything that comes out of his
pie hole here
well it may not have been the most
respectful precedent in terms of the way
it was rolled out by jim comey and the
reasoning that he employed but but i'll
take it in terms of the result and look
the the difference was incredibly there
was a striking difference between the
two situations hillary clinton had no
protection under the presidential
records act that had nothing to do with
her at all why do they keep quoting the
presidential records act like like gets
some kind of right he has is not opposed
to the law he [ __ ] broke what why do
they keep doing this not only that but
the law he broke and the law that he
made even more strict right before he
left right he was like yeah yeah this
this actually like two years you're
making a felony yeah yeah we're gonna go
five years we're gonna yeah
i don't understand why they keep
referring to it as if he it's like they
they're like he has the right to these
because he was the that's not what that
thing says at all like it doesn't say
it's not even close he cannot take it
and just go he's like
i'm gonna take this to go okay like he's
making some sort of order at a
restaurant like do you want it for here
at the white house or do you want to go
at marg mar-a-lago i mean it's like he's
driving through yeah it's like he's
driving through it's right for fast food
yeah he's like oh i'm gonna i'm gonna
pick it up to go and they're like that's
not how that works you can't just take
government documents and then go all
right got it see you guys later and no
you you just can't do that that's not
how you they weren't declassified i've
been asking this question if you're
going to eat because we know these
documents have left these folders if
you're going to eat
a classified document is it
do you put on a regular bun a sesame
seed bun what kind of bun do you oh no
bun no no bun no oh so it's just no no i
think there's i think there's several
ways you can eat so it's a low carb it's
a low carb it's a low it's a low carb
diet you put some ketchup on it you know
and you just you can roll it long or you
can take it you know sideways like a
wrap yeah you can make it a wrap you can
make it a hot dog you can make it a
hamburger depending on the shape you
want but yeah you're making me hungry
you can even make it into a taco i guess
classified taco
let's listen to dummy here
in terms of how you actually classify
these documents as only presidential or
personal the classification doesn't
matter she has a personal server that is
a
tremendously more uh insecure way of
having access that's why it's different
that's why it's different that's why
that's why james comey actually cascaded
hillary clinton he said it was
irresponsible for her to do that because
it was she had government information on
a private server it would almost be like
if she stole
digital documents yeah from the
government server and put it on her
server then can you imagine if that was
the case if she would have stole them as
she's walking out the door as secretary
of state she swiped a bunch of [ __ ]
government documents classified top
secret documents and then took him home
on a thumb drive and put him on her
computer oh i can i can just tell you
yeah the outrage the outrage if we got
you know that the same level probably if
they probably get more actually based on
the
the history of of republicans getting
mad at a tan suit and getting mad at
emails and it's just one of those things
where it's like as you accelerate based
on the controversies that are there
they're gonna make a big deal out of
something that is not from their own
party right so when it comes to these
documents which contain human
intelligence information they contain uh
uh data or information that should only
be read in a skiff they have information
relating to
nuclear secrets they just go
guys guys what it's it's his stuff it's
his stuff
president presidential record zach
why why are we making such a big deal
about this right i mean you had greg
gutfeld on on the five the other day
laughing
about
how this was all like oh you're trying
to relate this to this it's like he's
he's trying to belittle the fact that
our former president stole lied and hid
government top secret highly classified
documents and they're like yeah it's no
big deal it's like whatever well i mean
you know here's the thing is i really
think joe biden should take just
truckloads of top secret documents when
he leaves take take him over to delaware
why not yeah i mean apparently the
presidential record act lets you take
anything you want [ __ ] he should take
the [ __ ] furniture out of the white
house well not only that but as a as a
president if you have you know they're
saying oh you can unilaterally just like
wave a hand and say it's declassified
well if trump did that then biden could
also in this same moment say do that
classified right and then he gets to be
like you can't have these that are
classified so it's the same type of
[ __ ] when when they try to make an
argument like oh well we should we
should impeach this person okay well the
next person up is is harris okay well
the next person up is pelosi like they
don't think these three these things
through and so when they make an
argument that is of a like illegal
status or stature they go well this is
what this is what it is and it's like
okay well let's really think this one
through because if you're saying that
this is true then the other president or
the the current president biden could
also act the same way right with the
documents that he declares the same way
that you're saying well it reminds me of
that you remember that when they when
the gasoline was going up because russia
invaded a sovereign country and well you
mean because biden hit the switch on his
desk right yeah and they they put we're
putting stickers i did that on the gas
pumps pointing to the price and now as
the price is going down the sticker's
still there saying i did that like they
didn't have the foresight to go
and eventually to go down like it was
only only gasoline only goes up it never
goes down same thing with the let's go
brandon you know you co-op the message
and you say actually we're going to use
that for this and now they're really
upset at the dark branding thing right
because they do not have the foresight
they do not future proof their dumb ass
ideas so when [ __ ] turns the other way
against them and for the democratic
party they're like oh [ __ ]
oh no no no and they're rushing all over
the place and trying to trying to peel
the stickers off the gas pumps but
that's that's why that's why
yes this morning they're freaking out
because joe biden is rallying democracy
to defeat them and they're freaking the
[ __ ] out now you found a speaking of
this jim is it jim trustee is that what
he's doing james james trustee is his
full name but he goes by jim
jimmy trusty here you found the draft
version of a commercial that he did is
that right yeah i found on the the deep
dark brandon webb okay well let's
let's let's play this draft version of
the commercial that he's gonna air soon
is your patriotic voice being cancelled
did you try to overthrow the government
are you a former president who stole
highly classified documents well then
you need a lawyer you can trust
hi i'm jim trusted and i'm a lawyer
really when i was charged with smearing
my own [ __ ] on the walls of the capitol
on january 6th jim was there to defend
me and thanks to him i only got to serve
16 months in prison i also teached
criminal courtroom evidence and trial
advocacy at the university of maryland
when i took jim trustee's course i
learned that stealing government
property was like as serious as like an
overdue library book oh and i almost
forgot now you can follow me on twitter
for unsolicited legal takes so when you
need a lawyer you can trust remember to
call jim trustee for just 184 easy
payments of 99.99 jim trustee will maybe
help you too no money back guarantee
oh he changed his website and his phone
number but um yeah it looks like he's
getting i'm not saying that's his real
phone number oh but but that's his real
phone number
well i mean he put it out there he he
put it he's advertising and he's
advertising we're just trying to make
sure i'm just saying show you the facts
he actually and
i don't know if you can hear it but i
said you know you would normally say i
taught this class
but on the university of maryland
website for where he is a professor yep
or he is he is a professor
what he does
or what they did was they wrote
he teached
no no they didn't he did yeah i'll find
him right now he teaches oh they didn't
these classes so i tried to repeat it
but i don't know if i came across when i
was doing the and i was like stuff in my
face that by the way that was you know i
thought that was jim joseph that was
just jim trustee yeah no he was 100 jim
trustee
jim trustee who else do we got on the
list we had we got christina bob on the
list
christina bob we've we've ran into
christina bob a lot here at the tony
michaels podcast over the last year
because we know who christina bob is
she's not fooling us she's not fooling
us here at the johnny michaels podcast
she was in the war room
um with
with
john eastman
rudy giuliani steve bannon trying to
overthrow our government now let me show
you a picture of that here
here it is here um this is uh again you
see john eastman here you see rudy
kaluti uh grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani and then christina bob right
here everyone wants to make her out to
be an oan propagandist which she is that
she is yeah but she was in the
department of homeland security she was
an executive secretary
she's never really been an attorney
until she had to be one for trump
obviously because some of the bones did
that [ __ ] she said is there something
specific bone hinted that she that she
said this week that we want to that we
want to play
i'm trying to recall i i'm i'm honestly
doing a catalog in my brain right now of
all the dumb things that they've said
well we definitely have one for uh alina
habba
right yeah i'm trying to think if
christina i mean like a shitty legal
take
[Laughter]
well here you go
um
it's the christina bob that uh
actually um this is what started it off
that was the original video that this
one here
the yeah the one with the pink in front
of it was like is she in front of a
green screen kind of situation yeah yeah
she's trying jupiter but that one's on
jupiter yeah yeah that was she's she's
definitely on another planet
uh
that is
[Laughter]
but [ __ ] so in this one this is when it
all really started right this is where
it's so this is her justification of him
stealing top secret documents this is
this is the uh the original it might
have been planted [ __ ] i think yeah uh i
i don't think that there was actually
anything there that's worthwhile i will
see what they come up with you know if
they did it'll be interesting especially
since they precluded me from actually
watching what they did
but but at this point i don't
necessarily think that they would even
go to the extent of trying to plant
information i think they just make stuff
up
and you know come up with whatever they
want and i i that's the way that they
will have to proceed in order to
actually try to indict the president
because
they don't have anything there's just
nothing there
oh boy this one this one was evergreen
wasn't it gabe
oh my god i mean the [ __ ] buffoonery
the bonehead injury here is just
astounding this again this is back when
when they originally
served
yeah this was august 9th so the day
after is when she
it's him that's goddamn long
holy yeah yeah man like dude i've been
trying to work on a honestly i've been
trying to work on a what was that
segment for this and i'm like oh maybe i
should wait till this and now that this
inventory list has come out i'm like
okay maybe i can finally make one you're
gonna keep doing like a half an hour
you're gonna have to do like a half an
hour on it it honestly might be the
longest segment it won't be a half hour
but it might be like maybe 10 12 15
minutes
long it's gonna be long especially with
all these clips of these dumb [ __ ] in
here i know christina bomb this this is
the most evergreen clip
it aged so beautifully
in the matter and in a matter of three
weeks it went from like uh that's a
that's a dumb take to oh man that is the
dumbest of
well what's what's even better is the
other attorney that we have on the
bonehead list yeah she's like oh all
kinds of people are in and out of this
spot like all
christina bobbie is trying to make the
argument that there was nothing there
there's no way they'll find anything
yeah there's no way and of course they
found all kinds of [ __ ] we have the list
one of those things that they keep
talking they keep saying stuff and they
keep going no no no it's not as bad as
it looks it's this is they planted it uh
it wasn't serious this this and that
like they're coming up with all these
you know bone-headed answers and and and
responses and takes and then the doj
goes okay look we didn't even want to
make this thing public but because you
guys keep saying [ __ ]
we have to respond and every time we
respond we show a little bit more like
we we allow you to peek behind the
curtain with with information that is
that can be actually shared and doesn't
actually reveal certain like sensitive
information so every time they do that
republicans maga trump his lawyers they
all look like [ __ ] dumb asses they've
got egg on their face
and they keep smiling
and trying to work through it right well
here's one white house attorney who used
to be in trump's realm
who has um definitely exited but this
attorney i feel like he's sending this
message not to just john eastman but all
these attorneys that are on tv let's
listen
to hershman here
oh it's it's not oh it doesn't have the
sound it's a gif get get get the
greatest criminal defense attorney
you're going to [ __ ] need it that's
what he said i thought it was a i
thought it was a video
they [ __ ] tricked me oh man like
twitter two good dudes
they tricked you they [ __ ] me they
[ __ ] me hard yeah you bastards oh here
here here maybe this one maybe that's
when i have it uh here's another one
of the transition
i said good job now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're gonna need it get a great
criminal effin defense attorney you're
gonna need it
oh my god wise wise advice for anyone
who is associated with trump
right just in the same room as him yeah
yeah
if you're even describing this like like
all these people who went in that room
who took pictures in that room who who
publicly posted them
i bet the fbi is going down that list to
try to figure out if those people saw
that [ __ ] yeah they were within [ __ ]
arm distance of top secret information
and i pointed this out the other day
that kyle rittenhouse was in that room
yeah and i know a lot of people like
what's in significance of that listen if
he was willing to let kyle rittenhouse
put his scumming little murderous hands
on these [ __ ] documents that are our
documents that are the highest
secrets in our government you don't
think you'd sell them to the saudis yeah
you don't think you'd just [ __ ] give
them away to russia for whatever the
hell he wants you don't think he would
do that unload a classified folder full
of top secret information i don't know
that could i don't know how much how
many folders it will hold two billion
dollars worth of classified documents we
should ask jared maybe but i'm just
telling you but trump i mean the the
other thing too that that we need to
really acknowledge is the fact that
trump is an egomaniac he he is a
narcissist he thrives on people
complimenting him and doing what he says
and being the the smartest person in the
room
so when he has guests in there
what does he have to offer because
there's nothing really more than like oh
i was president for four years and you
love me and oh this is great thumbs up
now the cherry on top would be he goes
hey check this [ __ ] out i've got these
documents that no one else has and
nobody knows that i have them and
they're like
100
the government does know that you have
them and they're coming for your ass but
the idea that he would go to around
people and be like yeah you gonna want
to check this document out let me just
go into my [ __ ] desk drawer
and open it up well that's why he got
the dishonorable mention or no he got
alpha cuck this week yeah he got out he
got neon he got alpha guys
because every
every time he tries to challenge the doj
they put him in the [ __ ] corner
and they're like you want to watch fine
[ __ ] make sure your eyes are open
while we do this like we will [ __ ]
and you watch
well i think we should play the tape
here where he um
he projects we played this the other day
but this is this is he's he's phoning it
in he continues the phone he literally
is phoning in it right he's literally
phoning in his confession here um i i'm
not kidding he's confessing to a lot of
[ __ ] here in this just i mean it's 42
seconds and he he he admits to like
three federal crimes here on this 43
seconds it's insanity but let's listen
to the um
the the alpha get cucked here and let's
listen a lot of people think that when
you walk into my office i have
confidential documents or whatever it
may be all details you do you did until
they came and got this [ __ ] a lot of
people a lot of people think yeah a lot
of people do think that now right
you
you you saw this thing right you caused
the doj to release this [ __ ] and unseal
it and they said
okay fine yeah well i mean really he was
the one that got the doj involved in the
first place all he had to do was take
the [ __ ] little bit of slack that
nara was giving him on these classified
documents when they're like hey we need
our [ __ ] this stuff is highly sensitive
you cannot have this stuff yeah this is
not stuff you can have not only is it
not yours you are not allowed to have
this [ __ ] yeah we they warned them
let's listen classified but i had
confidential documents spread out all
over my far floor yeah you sure did you
sure did you were upset at the fact that
they made it look sloppy which by the
way is the standard way in which you
photograph a [ __ ] crime scene they
laid it out in an area that was
available to them and they took a photo
with the ruler and the evidence marker
and said great cool in the frame this
gives you an idea of what was stashed in
that box with those time magazine frame
covers
right because and that's that's why that
box is sitting there because that's the
[ __ ]
box that's the box that it was in it's
really ridiculous okay let's let's
continue let's hear some more confession
here because he doesn't stop he doesn't
stop it saying i had classified
documents in my office because he said
some people are saying and then he
admits to it then he admits to it no
what
what
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy
and uh like a slob
like i'm sitting there reading these
documents all day long or somebody else
reading
the guy can't read do you hear the
background there's someone laughing in
the background of this audio they're
like
you can't and that's that's what i'm
thinking like when they're laughing when
he says like i'm sitting there reading
doctors in their lap like you can't you
can't [ __ ] read that's funny he's
like he's like oh dude yeah he's like oh
they're laughing at my joke and they're
like no you are the joke well i mean
when he says i'm just sitting around
looking at these documents
it's exactly what you're saying he has
this [ __ ] stash in his office the [ __ ]
that he wants to show people
is the [ __ ] that was in his office
and he knows where it's at and he's got
three of them in his destroy that are
ready and available to brad to have
bragging rights that he has top secret
information
let's continue
it's so it's so dishonest
when you look at it and so people were
so he says he's all those things are
telling you all that stuff is true yeah
it's all true but it's so dishonest it's
so dishonest that they made me look like
a slob yeah i i committed treason and
violated the espionage act and i took
those documents without permission and
there wasn't any log of these documents
there wasn't any communication with the
the agencies that actually classified
them so that they could declassify them
like there's no paper trail he just took
it and said mine and then now he's
saying well i declassified them and
people think i'm just looking at them
yeah you probably are you probably do
look at that [ __ ] every day to be like
i'm the president like that's the type
of mindset he has where he's like
today's classified folder will be the
bombing of xyz right like it'll be
something and then that's with the
things that he's like oh you want to
check out this this cool classified file
i've got well we're only 23 seconds into
this buffooners can you imagine listen
to this entire interview let's listen to
the last few tens of seconds we're
concerned because they said gee
you know that's a strange scene you look
at the floor and you see documents right
they have cover sheets of documents no
they put them there john and they put
him there in a messy fashion and then
they took a picture
and they released it to the public and
this is what we're dealing with with
these people do you remember the uh the
the documentary interview where he's
like i look orange i look like why did
he like comment why are you orange why
do i look can we fix that
why do i lick horn this is the same [ __ ]
i mean here's here's my question is
they're so upset they're like oh he made
it look sloppy and they put it on the
ground this and that like i don't know
what the actual layout of his office is
because we only see the photos where he
takes with people and he gives the
[ __ ] dumbass
thumbs up right right
but one of the kim jones yeah in front
of the i'm shaking kim jong-un's hand
and all this stuff
but when you
stop and really think about this
would he
would he have been like okay or like
happier if they had like neatly stacked
them right in like three rows a four
column like is that what he had been
would okay with
would republicans not be outraged if
they just laid them out next to each
other
in a in an organized fashion
i i like that's what i'm trying to
that's what that's what i'm trying to
understand here i
if if you're trying to find logic in
that 42 seconds of nonsense that we just
listened to everyone's got a grandpa out
there right i mean everyone is and a
grandpa and you know grandpa reaches an
age where half the time when he's saying
[ __ ] it doesn't make any sense it just
doesn't make any sense he's saying all
kinds of [ __ ] you smile and you nod and
you go yeah grandpa yeah that's a great
story
the only thing is the difference between
my grandpa and this grandpa is my
grandpa didn't violate the [ __ ]
espionage act
well
you know i would also say that probably
for most of our viewers and anyone
watching is that their grandpa
didn't also violate the espionage act
isn't it isn't a treasonous traitor
who stole government documents that were
not his speaking of traders
treasonous traders uh we had
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas the supreme court justices
dishonorable mention uh i think i think
this story got buried this week and i'm
glad you made her the dishonorable
mention at the last moment here yeah
because i think this is
important to recognize as we go into
september in these january 6 select
hearings are going to break out jeannie
thomas needs to sit in the chair
hopefully the vice former vice president
mike pence and jeannie thomas will sit
in the chair for questioning whether
it's public or private and i think they
both need to sit for this but kyle
griffin has here breaking washington
it's a washington post story
jeannie thomas pressed lawmakers to
overturn joe biden's 2020 victory not
only in arizona which she emailed 29
lawmakers in arizona as previously
reported but also in a second
battleground state wisconsin
according to the emails obtained under
state public records law so she was
she was really heavily deep in this
state electors um campaign
and i'm telling you i think this is
where the doj is going to pounce on
these son of a [ __ ] and and any
criminals whether it's state federal
these boneheads like
jeannie thomas here um who got
dishonorable mentioned this week for for
finding out that she wasn't doing in
just one stage she was doing in a bunch
of them and the reason why that's so
significant is because they were trying
to get a slate of electors that could be
switched for president vice president
pence to declare donald trump the
dictator and king so that's how we got
um jeanne johnson again we talked about
this you know uh when this was yesterday
the day before that this dropped uh but
again
it is insane to think that we have the
wife of a sitting supreme court justice
clarence thomas his wife jenny thomas
was just sexting
with with mark meadows and sending these
seditious texts right going at it and
saying we need to make sure that we
don't make biden president we need to
make sure that donald trump is present
because he's going to save us you know
spreading q anon conspiracy theories
because that's what she is she is a q a
nut
but
the fact that we have someone who not
only was texting mark meadows who was
the chief of staff to donald trump but
was also emailing
arizona
uh to to get those state electors and
then we find out that it was also
wisconsin like i maybe there's more i
wouldn't doubt it for the other swing
states like pennsylvania probably
michigan whatever it might be
but i guarantee that she had further
communication this might be just the tip
of the iceberg and i really do hope the
doj comes in and goes okay enough is
enough as if the other things weren't
enough to show intent
and to show malicious intent to go
against our democracy
but at this point i'm like i hope i hope
they go after her and and make her
testify subpoena her hold her you know
hold her and make her her actually speak
to the questions that the the jan six
committee has because
right now she's just free floating
just i know as an open trader speaking
of flee for flee free floating traders
billboard was apparently just on fox
news this is kind of breaking and he's
talking about the documents and the
boxes that we were just talking about um
let's just let's just uh listen to it
here and see what dummy has to say
i can't think of a legitimate reason why
they should have been could be taken out
of the uh government away from the
government if they're classified i
frankly am skeptical of this claim that
i declassified everything you know
because frankly
i think it's highly improbable and
second if in fact he sort of stood over
uh scores of boxes not really knowing
what was in them and said i hear about
him classify everything in here that
would be such an abuse
uh and uh that and
show such recklessness that it's almost
worse than taking the documents oh my
god so here is bill barr this piece of
[ __ ] yeah there are this is not this
does not absolve him of anything that he
did by the way no but let me tell you
something when bill barr is going on fox
news
fox news and saying hey
him claiming that he declassified all
this [ __ ] is worse than him taking it
when bill barr says that out loud on fox
news this guy's in big [ __ ] trouble
he's in big trouble and i think bill
barr is signaling to people he's gonna
go to prison
for this dummies you better stop
defending it because he's gonna go to
prison this guy was this guy was one of
the most ruthless trump defenders as the
attorney general of the united states
this is not some [ __ ] schlub this guy
was this guy made sure to bury the
[ __ ] mueller report so that trump
wouldn't be indicted on charges for
russia collusion right or the fact that
that he tried to get bar and bar was
like yeah we'll use the doj to protect
you from eating carol right like with
that lawsuit right he's like whoa whoa
whoa what what are we doing here guys
that is not what you should be using
your power for that scumbag is the one
that's the one who is now saying hey you
need to stop defending this guy because
his argument it doesn't matter which
argument he makes they're both really
treasonous arguments
if i were to quote bill barr right now
it's [ __ ]
right right right well speaking of
[ __ ] uh it brings us to our winner
bone end of the week
elena habba oh my god you talk about
[ __ ] i don't know where she comes up
with these legal takes i don't know
where she got her [ __ ] law degree
from but it doesn't seem like she even
has a law degree to be quite honest with
you i don't think she'll have a law
degree much longer especially you know
especially for christina bob they're
making these accusations i know it's
ridiculous well it's so much so that
they got their own sitcoms
let's watch let's watch this episode of
shitty legal takes here uh featuring
elena habba
[Music]
what what's happened is now they've put
this picture out so that you would
assume and i am somebody who has been
and the press loves to talk about this
especially today i'm somebody that has
been in his office i've seen it this is
not the way his office what has she seen
his office or is it i don't know what it
is i mean it is the office but i think
as a lawyer it's important that you are
very specific with your words right
right and it is kind of generic but
let's let's continue
they give you this appearance that you
walk in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about hey
they don't understand
something that was 2a she says a yeah
that was 2a yeah yeah that's the that's
the picture like she's walking straight
into it mark top secret could be mark
classified the presidential records act
he would have said this is declassified
it doesn't get a new marking all the
time he's left the office all the time
she even admits it doesn't get a new
marking
i mean most of the time like
every single every single time every
single time it gets a mark like maybe
there's one or two instances where it
didn't that was a mistake and probably
someone paid the price for that but yeah
you know
jesus it is a complete public spectacle
and i'm not really going to stand by it
anymore you know i personally think that
means what's hilarious about the public
spectacle thing is it was them that did
this they made the public spectacle yeah
like literally nara doj wanted to keep
this under wraps they did not want this
out in the public they did not want to
make this a they really didn't want to
do this thing where they released the
photo released it uh the affidavit
released the [ __ ] inventory list they
didn't want to do that they did not want
to do that but even even further back
even further back you have to remember
that in january nara made a visit down
to get those 15 boxes and again like
you're pointing out this whole thing
could have been avoided by one not
stealing the documents right but two
not playing this cat and mouse game for
18 to 20 months and saying we don't have
the documents we swear we don't have the
documents we have written down as a
lawyer representing trump we don't have
the documents we gave you all the
documents you know as they go down and
they go back and forth and nara was like
okay you know what we're just going to
put this timeline on our website and
we're going to let everyone know this is
the communication that happened and
those emails were also released because
the lawyers and trump continued to
challenge and say this was all made up
they were the one planning evidence and
they're like look we have the [ __ ]
receipts here they are right we have the
emails back in money when we were
talking what's funny about all this if
you really think about this
the people that are gonna take down
trump here
are [ __ ] librarians okay
literally
librarians at the national and i don't
i'm not trying to they're doing great
work and they catalog everything what
i'm trying to say is librarians usually
are very smart they have great memories
and they document everything they
document everything jesus you take a
book 20 years later they know you still
have that goddamn book yeah and it is
librarians that are going to take down
trump this is hilarious let's continue
to listen to this bonehead intimidated
people have tried to intimidate it's not
going to work you can't just put a
picture like this and say look
did the fbi do that or was that the way
that that would look before they went in
there do you have any any first hand
yeah i'm sure you've seen the press
today i do have first-hand knowledge as
you know i have been down there i'm down
there frequently i have never seen that
i have never ever seen that that is not
the way his office looks anybody that
knows president trump's office he has
guests frequently there it is
it's just a joke they literally must
have gone in and taken out documents
they wanted or cover letters as it is
and put it about so that the public
believes that this is top secret
documents that were on his floor
it's ridiculous i can they were top
secret documents on the same
part out loud
she's like admitting oh my god she's
such a bonehead she goes yeah i went
down there i saw those documents
yeah yeah no i saw i saw those documents
and yeah there were there were frequent
guests that came down there i don't know
guys i don't know what the big deal is
why does why do people keep freaking out
right i have no idea where she got her
law degree and how he found this
attorney i have no idea maybe she snuck
in um with the russian spy who claims to
be a roth child let's give
habba her due for bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well gabe it was pretty close between
habba and bob yeah and uh
it was back and forth the whole night i
know i know it was close between the two
of them so thanks for voting for bone
end of the week don't forget to go
follow at tony michael's pod to vote
every single week for bone end of the
week and you can watch bonehead of the
week every single friday here in the
second hour the tony michaels podcast
and also the replay on the midas touch
network's youtube page don't forget to
go over there and subscribe you're not
going to want to miss the replay in
prime time every friday night also
subscribe here at the tony michaels
podcast if you're on minus touch
watching come over to the tony michaels
podcast watch us every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
monday through friday and also
simulcasting at the midas touch facebook
page you can also download every single
episode on apple spotify google wherever
you get your podcast and listen in make
sure to leave a review while you're
there
gabe
it's been a hell of a theme with these
lawyers this week but um we made it
through we made it through the week i'm
sure the weekend's just gonna give us
plenty more news on monday yes plenty
more news on monday monday for the
holiday
which by the way are we doing a show on
monday
well i mean i planned on it yeah you
want to take off i'm i'm good to go i
can i've got nothing else going on right
i'll see you on the show all i do is
yell and scream into a microphone that's
all i do is yelling screams and
microphones so join us on monday
if you're here at the tony michaels
podcast stick around but if you're on
the minus touch
youtube channel thanks for joining us
for this edition of bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]